um when I had initially gone to true
leave which is a dispensary here in the
state of Florida when I had gone over to
Tampa to listen to one of their classes
for guys who are suffering from PTSD or
from traumatic brain injury and I got
over there they you know brought
everybody out I initially asked the
question hey can you overdose on
cannabis of course everybody in the room
kind of broke out laughing and listen I
don't know for sure I mean us I need to
know and the doctor was here said it's
impossible for you to overdose on
cannabis and I said why is that and she
said listen most of the chemicals in our
body that are pain relieving are kept in
the brain stem she goes so we we take
that that a chemical that's in there and
we copy it and we make us synthetically
and we can introduce it to your body the
problem is that if you get too much of
it the same thing as your brain stem
done which is regulates your breathing
or your heart or your your nerves
function so by overdosing on that you
can cut those functions off they didn't
find out till 1998 that our bodies
actually have an endocannabinoid system
in there and there's some doctors now
that are looking at it from a
perspective of hey these
endocannabinoids systems actually play a
role in cancer and we believe that when
your endocannabinoid efficient that
cancer has a much greater process of
showing up so I I started to understand
uh since so tell me more about this
endocannabinoids system in our bodies
and what it does and she said basically
as you ingest cannabis and she said we'd
like them not for you to smoke it
because obviously still a carcinogen but
by ingesting it has her true benefit to
the body by releasing this into
cannabinoids and keeping your body
really at a higher rate of the ability
to not get cancer or to have some of
these terminal diseases so she said
there's still because it's been
federally illegal we haven't able really
to study it we recognized that within
the traumatic brain injury and when you
look at football players and/or the guys
I were sitting with who'd been blown up
I'm in fact the scout sniper I told you
that was with us as I had two different
episodes we was actually blown up he's
wearing a helmet came for one of them
and was suffering from it so when I
asked the doctor I said listen I need to
know more about how the hell does
cannabis work on in somebody who has
traumatic brain injury and I said to
keep itself
because I'm not that guy yeah so she
said hey listen it's like this she goes
the nerves long it has these things
called
axioms at the end and as you have these
these impact for the brain these axioms
get closer if the axioms touch it kills
that part of the brain for some reason
she said when people smoke cannabis it
makes that nerve longer so those those
those axioms kind of move away from each
other and so that's that's what I said I
was like really so I'm gonna so the next
thing I had with me that day dance man
oh it's amazing well and listen I had
another one with me where was a
gentleman who was suffering from
Parkinson's disease he was in Kentucky
this was not cannabis related it was
hemp related and CBD and CBD true CBD
hemp oil only has point zero zero three
THC so it's not like there's anything in
there that's going to create a euphoric
feeling mm-hmm
this poor guy was suffering from
Parkinson's disease so bad that he was
she couldn't get his coffee in his mouth
he was shaking so hard as he came up to
his mouth so she brought in some of this
oil it was in a kind of like a syringe
and squeezed it into his mouth and
within four minutes he stopped shaking
and I don't think it's crazy how that
come on yeah I mean there's this real so
I'm telling the doctor do you think
that's real I mean how how could the
medical profession not know this this
poor guy is shaking 24 hours seven days
a week for the rest of his life one you
can give him that which contains no THC
and he stops within four minutes of
shaking and she started laughing she
said listen let's call the doctor I know
this doctor that's in this video let's
call her and he said before I tell you
this before we call them as a doctor if
I lied to you intentionally I run the
risk of losing my license so I can she
does I can tell you right now that this
doctor doesn't want to lose her license
so I I know there's no deception going
on here but let's let's find out what's
really going on so she called her up and
you know we broke into a 10-minute
dissertation about what we were looking
at she said listen at the end of the day
I said to her how do you know this guy
just doesn't have his own agenda and
this is his way of tricking the system
so that oh we've got to have this right
I know legal and she said listen it's uh
I agree with what you're saying I didn't
have something actually hooked up to him
that would say hey you know this is what
his heart rates doing this is this
azar going on she just but I have a
nine-year-old girl and when I gave her
this stuff it does the same thing to her
and I can assure you the nine-year-old
girl doesn't have a an agenda so again
so these these benefits of cannabis or
again in this case it's hemp are
unbelievable and I think that when you
start looking across the board as to
what it could do to help again to the
vets I'm all for it
that's that's my continued push in this
whole this whole process yeah that's
another huge thing is young kids with
cancer you know being in treatment for
that bingos and just legalized here in
Florida also you can now if your child
is suffering from one of those diseases
you can actually legally now again it'll
probably be at the end of this month
when it's actually goes through the
Senate and becomes law but you'll
actually be able to do that now in
Florida where parents before who lived
in other states would have to move from
that state to Colorado let's say to be
able to treat their child right so also
and you figure out these kids are gone
from like having 15 or 20 seizures a
week it's like one a month
how can you again how can you not write
address that and say you know our laws
have been unjust I get why they brought
him into play they've been unjust